З одного боку - мігранти на білорусько-польському кордоні.
З іншого - скупчення російських військ.
Загрози на кордонах України вкотре розбурхали дискусію, чи здатний Київ протистояти зовнішнім небезпекам
і чи не надто пізно та хаотично реагує на них?
Створення міграційної кризи на кордоні Білорусі та Польщі має на меті відвернути увагу від дій Росії на кордоні з Україною
вважає держсекретар США Ентоні Блінкен.
Таку думку поділяють також багато інших закордонних партнерів України.
Я думаю, що Блінкен не дарма це сказав, він аналізує поточну ситуацію і дивиться на крок-два вперед.
По-перше, як ми бачимо, ця штучно створена криза вийшла в топ європейського порядку денного, глобального порядку денного,
і тим самим відволікається увага від інших конфліктних зон, у тому числі від конфлікту на Донбасі.
Мовляв, поки Україна фокусуватиметься на потенційних загрозах, пов'язаних зі імовірними спробами мігрантів
перетнути кордон України з боку Білорусі, це може створити влучний момент для вторгнення Росії зі сходу.
Виключати вторгнення не варто, оскільки ціна України для Путіна надзвичайно велика.
Поки що нічого критичного немає. Завтра Росія точно не розпочне широкомасштабне вторгнення,
але в неї є така можливість впродовж кількох місяців.
Сумніви українців, наскільки тверезо влада оцінює загрози на кордонах, виникли
після суперечливої реакції Києва на повідомлення про скупчення російських військ на сході.
Спершу Україна спростовувала інформацію про це, у той час як іноземні ЗМІ мало не щодня повідомляли про загрозу.
Згодом Зеленський таки визнав присутність російських військових, але заявив:
Скажемо відверто, на восьмому році війни така поведінка нашого сусіда нас не дивує і не лякає.
Склалося враження, що Київ недооцінює загрозу на східних кордонах України.
Експерти припускають, що це могло були тактичним маневром.
Якщо відсутні пресконференції чи презентації, це не означає, що цього немає.
Я розумію, що і президент, і головнокомандувач, і начальник Генштабу
мають розповідати принаймні частину того, що можна розказати суспільству.
Безумовно, що ведеться інформаційна робота з партнерами.
Безумовно, що наші військові, політичне керівництво отримують закриту інформацію
від наших західних партнерів, передусім США, я би це оцінив таким чином.
Разом з тим дії Києва, на жаль, далекі від тактики на випередження чи запобігання кризам.
Їх радше можна охарактеризувати як тактика "гасіння пожеж" - і це не найкращий варіант для України, вважають експерти.
Однозначно, чого немає - це заходів, які потребують стратегічного підходу.
Тобто не можна вирішити ситуацію такими антикризовими заходами.
Сьогодні виникла криза в україно-білоруських відносинах - значить, ми скликаємо РНБО
і моментально вживаємо якісь заходи, які нейтралізують.
Приміром, усе ще залишається невирішеним питання залежності України від енергопостачання з Росії і Білорусі.
У кризових ситуаціях це вразливе місце Києва і може використовуватися Кремлем для шантажу.
Ще один приклад "гасіння пожеж" - наміри "реанімувати" проєкт "Стіна",
започаткованого у 2014 році тодішнім прем'єр-міністром Арсенієм Яценюком на кордоні України і РФ.
За сім років проєкт так і не завершили, і наразі звели заледве половину від запланованого.
Проєкт неодноразово критикували за неефективність, його виконавців звинувачували у корупції та розкраданні коштів.
Тож, хоча опитані DW експерти й підтримують ідею облаштування українсько-білоруського кордону, однак побоюються повторення невдачі "Стіни".
Увага Європи нині прикута до білорусько-польського кордону.
Однак стверджувати, що про Україну забули не можна. По-перше, Київ отримав беззаперечну підтримку від західних партнерів.
Генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг застеріг Росію від агресивних дій щодо України.
Міністри закордонних справ Франції та Німеччини підписали спільну заяву,
яка містить попередження про "серйозні наслідки" для РФ у разі подальших спроб підірвати територіальну цілісність України.
А Великобританія заявила про готовність перекинути в Україну 600 спецпризначенців у разі посилення загрози вторгнення з боку Росії.
Експерти стверджують, що такої підтримки Україна не мала навіть у 2014 році.
Можу запевнити, що концентрація російських військ на кордоні з Україною викликає велике занепокоєння в Брюсселі.
Очевидно, криза на польському кордоні також спричиняє напругу, оскільки Польща і Литва - члени ЄС і НАТО.
Тому це має також бути вирішено.
Однак у Брюсселі розуміють, що військова загроза Україні має вплив не лише на Україну - вона впливає на безпеку Європи.
Експерти радять Києву переглянути свій захист кордонів: не лише реагувати на вже існуючі кризи,
а діяти на випередження і бути готовим до різних безпекових викликів.